labour's shadow business secretary
johnson reynolds is with us now
obviously we want to talk about cost of
living and the impact on so many of our
viewers before that though what's putin
up to
well he's losing and i think we've got
to stand firm in the face of the threats
and aggression frankly i feel sorry for
any
russian conscripted forces sent to
ukraine what we know so far is
well-trained forces well-motivated
forces with the right equipment
are the people with the advantage and
the success so far so we can never
underestimate putin but he's losing and
we've got to stick to what we're doing
um and um his
threat
about nuclear weapons says he's um he's
not bluffing how seriously should we
take that
we can't underestimate him as i say but
i think fundamentally that comes from a
position of weakness you know
even people sympathetic to ukraine
thought it would be very difficult for
them to hold out for maybe a week
against russian forces and what we've
seen has completely contradicted that
and that position of weakness leads to
what putin is saying today now i think
we have to be very firm in saying
there'll be severe consequences not just
for that threat but for any kind of use
of chemical weapons which we've seen
from russia in the past but
fundamentally we should take heart from
the fact he is losing the russians are
losing ukraine is going to liberate
itself we continue to support them
that's what we must do and the referenda
there is four separate referenda that
he's planning in regions um of ukraine
in order to annex those regions well i
think
the claim that russia made and has made
consistently towards ukraine that these
are people who wish to be part of russia
or be sympathetic or break away from any
kiev
orientated government is completely
contradicted by the treatment of
ukrainians by russian forces during this
conflict so i'm afraid i see no
legitimacy in the claims that he is
making in regards to the eastern side of
ukraine
what's going on in ukraine is very much
of course impacting on the living
standards of people here in the united
kingdom we have a mini budget it's not
being called that but that's what it is
on friday what are you hoping for from
it
well i'm hoping for something very
different to what has been trailed over
the last few weeks i want to see a real
plan for growth i accept all of us do on
the labor side the government's claim
and point that their their running of
the economy for the last 12 years has
been poor and it hasn't grown but what
i've heard from the government so far
doesn't fill me with any confidence they
understand what really needs to happen
so getting rid of the cap on bankers
bonuses or ripping up people's
employment rights that is not the way to
grow this economy for the benefit of
everyone it's not the way to grow it at
all and i'm afraid that joe biden is
right and liz trust is wrong in how they
see the economy and what needs to be
done so i would like a long-term
industrial policy i'd like reform of
business rights i would like to see that
the brexit deal improved all of the
things that would really benefit
economic growth and households and wages
in this country now i'm afraid i think
we won't get any of that and it'll be a
huge mistake but stimulating the economy
starts with
businesses getting back on their feet
and that would include i suppose bankers
who because they'll get no cap on their
bonus they'll want to work here more and
they'll stimulate the economy well i
don't agree with the premise of
trickle-down economics i don't think
well i think actually the government's
argument is is to do with the the way us
investment banks might transfer more
staff to london because they're
enumerated in different ways let's
remember i mean the current cap is is
200 percent of your basic salary 300
percent i think of shareholders agree it
was designed for not for punitive
measures but for economic stability
because of the risks that were taken
leading up to the financial crisis and
the idea that if you incentivize the
bonus based on certain behavior that
could make it riskier and actually
that's a threat to economic stability so
i'd like to see a compelling case from
the government but the idea that in
itself lifting the cap on bankers
bonuses will grow the economy when it
will not have any impact on 99.9 of of
people in this country and crucially
will undermine the big fight which is
against inflation because how will the
government say to public sector workers
or people in the private sector we don't
want to get into a 1970s wage spiral
limit your own claims oh but by the way
we're lifting the cap on bankers bonuses
i find that incoherent yeah just looking
at um the
cap
on energy bills though and that would um
that would suggest that you know a lot
of people will benefit from that and it
will also start to control inflation yes
well we led the way over the summer
saying there must be a cap and a
protection for households and businesses
from these rising energy prices
obviously i do expect the government
from what we've heard to be in the same
place when the details come out today do
you agree with how they want to pay for
it no i think that's the big difference
the two big differences are first of all
how it should be paid for and is there a
plan alongside that to reduce our
dependence on fossil fuels and our
exposure to those prices on on paying
for it we would raise a substantial
proportion of the money from a windfall
tax because for us business profits
enough though well actually if you
extend electricity generators you're
getting towards figures above 20 billion
pounds that's not an insignificant sum
of money fundamentally okay profits
should come from businesses innovating
disrupting markets providing services
not from an artificial spike in prices
from a conflict from russian aggression
in ukraine and a lot of business people
accept that case and i think the fact
the government wants to put all of this
cost onto households and says you can
increase spending cut taxes and somehow
that will all be fine because we're
going to rip up people's employment
rights and these supply side reforms
will make the difference i'm afraid that
is not a that's not a convincing case i
want to come back to the windfall tax
that you were just talking about who who
would you tax so the tax that we put
forward is the existing tax that the
government themselves are actually
sticking to partly we would take away
the loophole for fossil fuel investments
because that's not something we should
be incentivizing in an energy crisis and
if that was extended to electricity
generators as ed miliband has said that
the estimate for that would be somewhere
between 10 and 14 billion pounds
additionally that would be raised so
there is substantial money that could
ease the burden on households if the
government chose to do so but it's a
question of whose side they're on
another thing that might help is
fracking where are you with that well
we're completely opposed to fracking
unless the government's safety advice
has changed and i understand it isn't
going to change i can't see how any
community will go for that crucial issue
here is fracking will not even if it was
very successful and accepted by the
public reduce the price of natural gas
because it would be sold at the market
rate for the european commodity market
and therefore you'd have a bit more
liquidity in the market if you had more
supply in the uk but it can't reduce the
price and fundamentally what it will do
by by undermining the government's
claims on its ambitions on net zero and
the objectives which are legally set in
this country it will increase the risk
premium and the cost of capital for the
investments we really need in nuclear
renewables energy efficiency and these
mixed messages that this government
always sends to business are one of the
reasons why business investment is so
poor to the conservatives and one of the
reasons why economic growth has also
been so poor and until they understand
that these gimmicks these half measures
they put forward will simply not do the
job and they'll fail on their own terms
and reynolds always a pleasure thank you
very much thank you